also alle paar monate impfen und dann
möglicherweise dass auch durch eine
impfpflicht durchgesetzt wir alle also
wie steht eine pflegekraft dazu
krankenpflegerin linda roman ist bei uns
sie arbeitet in dem pflegeheim für
menschen mit behinderungen und auch im
krankenhaus schon guten tag frau human
impfpflicht um dann möglicherweise auch
eine impfung alle paar monate
durchzusetzen sind sie dafür
ich habe dazu gemacht ich wurde ja
relativ zu anfang geimpft und habe das
auch noch so zum schutz der anderen
gemacht und mittlerweile ist die angst
vor einem tödlichen verlauf einfach
größer als die angst vor der impfung
und klar war ich anfangs skeptisch aber
mittlerweile gestern meine booster
impfung erhalten
habe das natürlich auch zum selbstschutz
gemacht weil ich einfach angst vor einem
schweren verlauf habe und ich möchte
auch wie alle anderen wieder wenige
andere maßnahmen vollziehen müssen also
alleine die arbeit mit er fährt mit zwei
masken bei uns im bereich mit geistig
behinderten menschen das sehr sehr
schwer wir arbeiten ja auch teilweise
ohne sprache sondern nur über mimik und
gestik und mit den masken ist das
natürlich eine katastrophe für die leute
und wenn das dazu führt wieder ein stück
normalität zu haben und schwere verläufe
zu verhindern dann ja
frau huma nehmen sie uns einmal ein
bisschen mit in ihrem alltag sehen wir
schon ein bisschen berichtet anfangen
dieser krise da standen die menschen
noch am balkon haben applaudiert für
pflegekräfte jetzt fühlen sich aber
viele irgendwie zurückgelassen in dieser
krise sie arbeiten an vorderster front
helfen vielen menschen die sich gar
nicht selbst schützen können die
vielleicht auch gar nicht ihre stimme
erheben können in dieser krise wie gehen
sie damit um und wie gehen sie auch mit
dem respekt oder vielleicht an manchen
stellen sogar fehlenden respekt für
ihren beruf für das was sie leisten um
also für mich hat sich da wo natürlich
nicht nicht viel verändert ich stehe
schon immer voll und ganz hinter diesem
beruf und
ich merke dass bei den menschen
die geistig behindert und die haben
große angst und die sind einfach auch
darauf angewiesen dass wir uns schützen
damit wir weiterhin für diese leute da
sein können und ich finde das ist so
dieser knackpunkt also jede pflegekraft
sollte sich überlegen ist das wirklich
meine berufung und wenn ja dann bringt
es den leuten nicht wenn ich
krank oder gekündigt bin also dann muss
ich mich schützen um weiterhin für die
leute da sein zu können und dieser
mangelnde respekt diesen beruf gegenüber
ja das ist schon immer so aber mich
persönlich stürzt nicht dass die
bezahlung mangelhaft ist dass das ist
fakt ich hoffe da wirkt sich demnächst
irgendwie mal was was verändern aber das
ändert ja nichts an unserer täglichen
arbeit ich glaube jede pflegekraft die
pflegekraft mit herzblut ist macht das
nicht aufgrund des geldes sondern
aufgrund der berufung und nochmal als
korrektur ich bin altenpflegerin
das ist angekommen hierbei bild live
kennen sie um sich herum kolleginnen
kollegen die sich noch nicht am impfen
lassen
ja kenne ich und ich glaube dass der
der meist angegebene grund dafür dass
die menschen noch nicht geimpften ist
ungewissheit und angst aber also wie
schon so anfang gesagt die angst vor
einem schweren verlauf sollte größer
sein als bei einer impfung weil es gibt
ja auch schon eine masernimpfung in
krankenhäusern in kindertagesstätten und
da kräht kein hahn nach und das macht ja
auch sinn dass man sich selbst einfach
mit so einer impfung vor schweren
krankheitsverläufen schützen kann
linda wo man vielen herzlichen dank dass
sie sich zeit genommen haben in ihrem
mit sicherheit sehr anstrengen und
stressigen alltag heute mit uns zu
sprechen dann gehen gerne danke auch